that's a real dirty grandma it's a real
dirty grandma I was painting my nails
one time and my grandma Linda Horton
said that's a nice shade of poor red I
once got a Christmas card from her
signed maybe next year you'll because
that is the most diabolical Christmas
card I've ever I was playing piano for
my family when I was five
everyone clapped except my grandma when
I asked why she said I only cough if
it's good like me grandma but I mean
maybe she made you better for it no
you're too young for that
my grandma once offered a paper bag to
my brother to put over his girlfriend's
face yeah
brutal after I got my nose pierced my
grandma looked me up and down and said
oh you used to be my favorite
granddaughter last Thanksgiving my
grandma told me if your father with my
firstborn
I would have just started swallowing
from that point forward when I was 19 I
brought my boyfriend to meet my grandma
first thing she said then was soap in
ICU I fetch
she means that instead of having vaginal
intercourse she wouldn't swallow the
semen so she wouldn't get pregnant again
that's what she means